we take many things for granted these
days but as a materials engineer I've
always found it incredible how much we
take materials for granted everything we
build is dependent on these materials
they are so significant that we've named
entire periods of human history after
them from the Stone Age to the Space Age
they have all been made possible by the
materials we have at our disposal and
our mastery over their properties I've
spoken about aluminium and silicon
before but today we're going to talk
about one of the most influential
periods in human history the Iron Age
some of the earliest evidence of iron
being used as a material goes back as
far as 3500 BC in Egypt where beads of
iron taken from a meteor were found
meteoric iron was a highly prized
material due to its heavenly association
Tutankhamun was buried with a dagger
made of the material but meteoric iron
was the only naturally-occurring source
of iron at the time because iron reacts
readily wood oxygen to form iron ore
there is no oxygen in space so meteors
deliver this material to earth in the
form of humans could use without having
the technology to extract it from its
ore the Iron Age began at various points
across the world as humans started to
learn how to extract iron from its ore
and its end date varies between regions
- in Britain the rnh began in 800 BC and
ended when the Romans invaded in 43 ad
marking the start of the Roman Age if we
continue to define human history but the
materials being mastered at that time I
would argue that the iron age lasted
right up until a little over 150 years
ago when steel was first mass-produced
now wireless era is called the iron age
the best materials at the time were made
from steel they may not have known but
iron and steel are mostly the same
material before we go forward if you
haven't seen my material properties 101
video the words in this section may
confuse you a little if you haven't seen
it yet and don't have a background in
material science
I highly suggest you pause and go watch
that first so the main difference
between iron and steel is the amount of
carbon they contain anything with a
carbon content above 2% is cast iron in
general a higher carbon content results
in a harder and less ductile material
cast iron has a very high carbon content
which makes it very hard but also very
brittle as iron started to become more
popular
more and more of the early bronze
continents were replaced with cast iron
as it was cheap to manufacture and could
be fired more often without being
damaged but these material properties
meant the cast iron cannons had a
tendency to explode with no warning
making them dangerous to operate cast
iron is not suited for structural use
either in fact it's use in bridges in
the mid 19th century led to a series of
bridge collapses later these bridges
were rebuilt using wrought iron wrought
iron contains less than 0.8 percent
carbon which makes it a much better
material for applications like this as
it is ductile allowing it to bend under
loads without breaking but it has a low
carbon content which makes it a lot
softer than cast iron steel is between
the two with a carbon content between
0.8 and 2% giving it an ideal balance
between hardness and ductility the
history of iron is defined by our
ability to control the carbon content
art is the fourth most common metal on
the surface of the earth
just below aluminium but it reacts with
oxygen readily to form iron oxide ores
Ross is one form of iron oxide and
preventing it as a constant struggle in
structural maintenance the Eiffel Tower
has been painted 17 times since its
construction to protect it from the
corrosion every seven years about 60
tons of paint is applied to the Eiffel
Tower and the color of paint has changed
over the years the tower was originally
a Venetian red and has changed a few
times from a more yellowish brown to a
chestnut brown until the adoption of the
current specially mixed Eiffel Tower
Brown in 1968 because iron reacts still
readily with oxygen to form iron oxide
iron does not exist on the surface of
the planet any usable form the first
step to process iron is to remove that
oxygen in the mid Bronze Age the first
signs of production of iron are seen
most of this early iron was smelted in
these furnaces called Blue Mary's one of
my favorite channels on YouTube
primitive technology actually created a
miniature version in one of his videos
these blue Marie's heat the iron ore
using charcoal as a heat source the
burning of charcoal produces carbon
monoxide which reacts with the iron
oxide in the aura to form carbon dioxide
and iron the bloomery is heated above
the melting point of the impurities but
below the melting point of iron and so
as the fire rages material falls to the
bottom of the bloomery and the heavier
iron consolidates at the bottom while
the impurities form a molten pool called
slag which can be drained away and
other great channel on YouTube how to
make everything made a series about this
process when the iron is removed it is
in the form of this porous mixture of
impurities in iron it needs to be worked
with a hammer to consolidate the iron
while the waste material is beaten off
the material left over is wrought iron
which as we discussed before has a very
low carbon content these blue memories
produce very small quantities of iron
especially before the waterwheel was
introduced to drive the bellows which
allowed the bloomery to grow in size
while keeping the temperature high
enough despite the small quantities that
produced the blurring revolutionized
human life even beyond the obvious
military advantages of iron weapons are
nor is much more common than the copper
and tin that spurred the Bronze Age
allowing iron to be produced in many
areas these communities can make their
own tools and weapons without having to
import the material from abroad iron
plows are stronger and heavier allowing
farmers to plateau their land quicker
and thus grow more food a single farmer
could feed more people allowing more
people to dedicate their lives to
different trades society was becoming
more stratified and trade was increasing
and things began to accelerate even more
as we discovered better ways of
extracting iron like the blast furnace
blast furnaces increase the production
of iron dramatically the blast furnace
gets its name from the method that is
used to heat it pre heated air at about
1,000 degrees Celsius is blasted into
the furnace through nozzles near its
base blast furnaces do heat the iron
above its melting point along with flux
materials the flux is a chemical that
will combine with impurities allowing
them to be extracted easily in this case
the iron ore is mixed with limestone and
coke coke is a refined form of coal with
very little impurities and it works
similar to the charcoal in the blue
memories by producing carbon monoxide
when burned which in turn reacts with
the oxygen in the iron ore to remove it
as shown before the heat from the
process decomposes the limestone into
calcium oxide and carbon dioxide the
calcium oxide then reacts with the
silicon impurities in the ore to form
calcium silicate this along with other
impurities form a liquid layer of slag
that floats on top of the heavy molten
iron which can be drained away while the
heavier molten iron is tapped lower down
this method allowed vast quantities of
ore to be converted to iron quickly but
it has a drawback but higher
temperatures are in readily absorbs
carbon so the iron created in blast
furnaces had a very high carbon content
may
cast iron so an extra step is needed to
decrease the carbon content this is
called fining there were a number of
ways of doing this one way was in a
refinery where the cast iron is heated
back up which oxidizes the carbon the
material would then be beaten with a
hammer to knock the oxidized carbon out
of the material this process would be
repeated until wrought iron was produced
once again producing steel with this
method would have required incredible
skill but there were methods of
producing it in small quantities all me
demonstrated one of these when producing
crucible steel which was produced by
mixing wrought iron and cast iron in a
sealed crucible which prevented carbon
from the air from entering the material
when mixed the low-carbon wrought iron
and the high carbon cast iron would form
steel the puddling furnace was another
method of production that involved
heating the cast iron in a furnace that
separated the fuel and the iron the heat
from the hearth would then radiate
through the furnace and liquify the iron
iron became molten a worker would then
stir it to encourage the oxidation of
impurities all of these methods of
production were fueled and
labor-intensive making the end product
too expensive for general industrial use
and the average life expectancy of a
puddling furnace worker was just 30
years old due to the toxic fumes
produced with the expansion of the
railroads in the early 19th century the
pressure to develop a faster and cheaper
method was growing all our modern rail
trucks are made from high-strength steel
its superior hardness over wrought iron
allows it to resist rare this is a
difference between a worn steel rail and
a new one this kind of wear happened so
quickly with wrought iron that certain
sections of popular lines needed to be
replaced every six to eight weeks steel
also has a superior strength over
wrought iron allowing it to carry more
load if you watch my last video you'll
know why this shape helps the rail carry
even more load so you can see why
finding a method of mass production was
so important and this is where the
British metallurgist Sir Henry Bessemer
came in Bessemer designed a converter
that looked like this molten iron was
poured in here from a blast furnace and
hot air is passed through the bottom the
oxygen in the air oxidizes the
impurities in the iron the carbon reacts
to form carbon monoxide which is
expelled as a gas while the silicon and
manganese oxidized to form a layer of
slag this process was very fast in fact
early on it was a victim of its own
efficient
as I removed too much carbon and left
too much oxygen in the iron to combat
this another ally that I am definitely
about to pronounce wrong containing iron
carbon and manganese called Spiegel
Eisen was added ok the manganese would
react with the oxygen to remove it and
the caravan increased the carbon content
as needed but it had another problem in
the early days the process did not
remove phosphorus from the iron and high
concentrations of phosphorus make the
steel brittle so initially the Basinger
converter could only be used with aren't
obtained from ores with low phosphorus
concentrations which were scarce and
expensive this problem was later solved
by Welshman Sydney Gilchrist Thomas who
discovered that adding a chemically
basic material like limestone to the
process would draw the phosphorus into
the slag this availability of cheap
steel caused an explosion and growth in
the rail industry steel is so vital to
our daily lives that it is often
considered a measure of economic success
of a country a high production of steel
means a high demand for steel high
demand for steel means your country is
building infrastructure for example this
is a graph showing Chinese steel
production from the 1990s to present
showing the rapid rise of China as a
global superpower during their economic
reform without steel our buildings could
never have grown to the heights we see
today and bridges like the famous Golden
Gate Bridge would have never been
possible there is even more to learn
about Steel's fascinating history like
how the expert blacksmiths of Japan
managed to create the katana and they
learned how to carefully control the
crystalline structure of the steel to
forge the perfect blade but we'll talk
about that in another video thanks for
watching this was my last video through
2016 and I wanted to end it by first
thanking all of you for making this one
of the most incredible years of my life
I can't wait to show you what I have
planned for 2017 I want to end this
video with a message for a cause that's
very close to my heart on this day two
years ago one of my best friends died in
a car crash in Malaysia and his family
have set up a memorial fund in his name
for the Nepal youth foundation Nepal is
an incredibly beautiful country but
there's a lot of problems it has one of
the highest infant mortality rates in
the world and due to problems with the
internal conflicts the earthquake and
just lack of social welfare and
there's a lot of orphans in the country
the Nepal Youth Foundation is dedicated
to providing shelter food medical aid
and a good education to the young people
of Nepal I remember having this really
deep conversation with Tom and some
other friends on a little border town I
wouldn't even call it a border town it
was a horse on the border between Laos
and Thailand and for whatever reason I I
recorded this conversation just take a
look with teaching English as a
possibility because that I have this
thing where I want what I do to have
like a meaning in the world like I want
to change things for the positive and I
think teaching English I'd be to teach
English because I think I'll be a good
teacher and if I can go to some poor
country and teach a group of kids
[ __ ] good quality English they can go
out into the world and then they look
back 10 years time whenever right yeah I
had a good teacher in English actually
was his name was Tommy's he was pretty
good like me then I would that's a
better [ __ ] a brilliant thing to be
able to give to a group of children
right yeah yeah something I all want to
be able I'd like the whole website thing
is the whole point of it is engineering
education it's difficult because I
always think would get your anything
started yeah get another thought
something uneasy
I've worked him to in this back in
Hartman mmm my god I put up like just
four kind of probing forward and I put
up like a few videos on YouTube just
basic kind of engineering education on
and I'm like like ten fifteen thousand
views over Tom never got to fulfill his
ambitions but I did so I want to honor
his life by donating to a cause he
really cared about Tom volunteered in an
orphanage in Nepal and he constantly
spoke about how much he cared about the
people of that country so I'm donating
two thousand euro to the Nepal Youth
Foundation I hope you can match that or
donate whatever you can I really don't
expect anyone to but it would mean the
world to me if you did without Tom I'm
not even sure I'd be standing here
talking to you right now through all of
our adventures together Tom always
encouraged me to pursue my dreams and
his positive attitude to life really
rubbed off on me on
when I really needed it and I definitely
wouldn't have left my job to pursue this
dream if it wasn't for the shock of his
death making me realize that life is
just too short to be doing something
you're not passionate about so I hope we
can have a positive impact on the young
people of Nepal the way Tom had a
positive impact on every single person
he ever met in his life